something grandfather clock
don't tell me that's actually an item
goddamn I was having happy fun times
haha okay sorry
oh I didn't notice you were on bed
they're doing something ah
I'll go ahh is these giant pillars of
poo thank you see something in the
background there no those are the same
pillars I was just a that's three of 12
not bad for my first start spending can
go AF ow ah God No go bad timing Slendy
I just told you to eff off sorry about
that cuz he ain't gonna give me I don't
know if there was a page back there but
it doesn't seem like there would be
because I got too many faces ah no no go
I got not oh I am the general direction
that you was were
if I go no uh-uh
I think they improved the Slenderman
mechanic please you bastard
lady I don't Eleni you're no lady you're
lady but I
I'm back at the red dildo again where's
this the thing oh oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no I said no is
that an outside that is oh I get is one
big circle what I'm a goofy goober yeah
run please be here somewhere
teddy bear ah right back the address
[ __ ] you
you're a goofy goober oh I can make it
up [ __ ] the exit yeah I got it oh my
god yeah go go get back I'll spin you
bastards fin soup please ah big goofy
goofy goofy goober
Wow